[Musique]
une fête populaire cette fête des rois
celui qui tire la fève de la galette est
proclamé roi de la fève
[Musique]
imagination aussi pour ces objets sans
prétention que sont les fèves en
porcelaine obligatoirement présenté dans
les galettes des rois variant selon les
régions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la couronne la brioche certains
n'approuve un peu borative donc on fait
les galettes parce que il y a des gens
disons que c'est un peu plus non si vous
voulez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
souvent les gens de famille tirent les
rois le dimanche qui suit l'Épiphanie
si cette année je crois que le
6 c'est un samedi alors il est possible
que en famille
mais vous avez des gens qui achètent ça
dans les
administrations dans les usines et alors
quand il y en a qui a été roi il faut
qu'il en paye une autre
ce qui fait que la période des rois qui
brioche des rois s'étale sur trois
semaines
[Musique]
les gens comme la vie ne portent aucun
intérêt à l'affaire du fait que vous
tombez sur quelque chose quand vous
mangez une brioche et bien c'est gagné
le cochon qui est là qui porte la date
1917 était en fait
l'empereur allemand qui est coiffé du
gascapointe c'était une crise à ce
moment-là le poisson vous le savez était
le premier signe de reconnaissance des
chrétiens et je crois que bon on a voulu
là le faire figurer dans l'effet on peut
reconnaître cet avion avec le point
d'interrogation qui marque la traversée
célèbre de Costes et Bellonte et se
détruit de porcelaine qui contenait ce
message qui était roulé à l'intérieur
et roi j'avoue qu'autrefois la fève ça
valait aisément mais un peu de
porcelaine ne se peut digérer facilement
puisque roi je suis reine il me faut la
choisir ne puisse en vous offrir un
gâteau
[Musique]
iconographie souvent naïve écrite dans
la pierre sur le parchemin dans les
mailles pour cette fête de l'Épiphanie
célébrée aussi à la cour des rois de
France
en voyant la collection mademoiselle
boucher s'agrandir au fur et à mesure
au long du temps je me suis dit
effectivement qu'il serait intéressant
d'en trouver des origines
il s'agit de la fête des rois or il faut
bien se rappeler que dans l'Antiquité
chez des Grecs comme chez les Romains un
peu chez les Hébreux on a toujours élu
un roi ou un prince lors des banquets
on est des rois soit par les dés les
osselets et peut-être mais dans
l'Antiquité lointaine on n'a pas de
preuve qu'on a utilisé la fève pour cela
mais ça paraît probable en tout cas ce
qui est vrai c'est que les gens se
réunissaient discours est mangez bien me
buvez un peu beaucoup quelquefois mais
se réunissait très amicalement avec un
roi qui monnaie en somme des discours
qui menaient le cérémonial
voilà alors ça ça nous en sommes encore
que avant la période chrétienne on a dit
un certain nombre de Jésus était né le 6
janvier et puis il y a une concile de
Trente ou non pour harmoniser tout cela
pour christianiser la fête de Noël il
paraissait préférable de dire que Jésus
était né le 25 décembre mais le 6
janvier restait vacant alors
heureusement il y avait depuis la
légende des Rois Mages qui d'abord
n'était que des mages puissent tout d'un
coup pour sans doute parce que la
royauté a toujours exercé une espèce de
fascination sur tous les esprits surtout
chez les humbles on les appelait les
rois mages et alors de là comme on
continuait de toute manière à fêter le 6
janvier coûte que coûte puisqu'on le
faisait autrefois et bien on se dit ce
sera la fête des Rois Mages et voilà en
fait comment est venu la fête des rois
et la fête des Rois Mages où il y a un
sacrétisme de plusieurs légendes de
plusieurs coutumes et on pourrait dire
de plusieurs religions
[Musique]